نور الدين ما الذي ترصده من الجانب الروسي
وربما المقاربه الروسيه لهذه التطورات على
اكثر من جبهه
نعم سفيان كما اشرت على اكثر من جبهه لابد
ان ننطلق من الجبهه الشماليه والشماليه
الغربيه في الحدود ما بين روسيا واوكرانيا
الحديث هنا يمكن ان نبداه بالقصف الذي
تعرضت له العديد من المناطق داخل روسيا
نتحدث عن نتحدث ونتحدث عن كورسك هاته
المناطق التي شهدت منذ صباح هذا اليوم
مجموعه من الاستهدافات سواء عبر قوات
المدفعيه الاوكرانيه او عبر طائرات مسيره
لحد الساعه ليست هناك اي اصابات لكن هناك
تخريب وتدمير للبناء التحتيه لعدد من
المدارس وعدد من المؤسسات هذا يعطي
انطباعا اوليا على ان روسيا تحاول بشكل او
باخر ان تضغط بهذا الاتجاه باتجاه
اوكرانيا لمنعها من القيام اي محاولات
خاصه ان المعلومات الاستخباراتيه التي
وصلت الى روسيا على ان هناك اعداد على
مستوى هذه الجبهه على مستوى العتاد على
مستوى القوات على مستوى المسيرات وهو ما
يحدث فعلا حاليا من اجل ضرب العمق الروسي
لذلك نرى بان القوات الروسيه تتحدث الان
عن استهداف لمناطق خاركيف وهناك حديث على
ان هناك مسيرات ربما وصلت الى تلك المنطقه
والحديث الروسي دائما ان وصول مسيرات او
وصول صواريخ الى هذه المنطقه الى منطقه
خركيف الى منطقه خركيز هي بالدرجه الاولى
لاستهداف هذه المواقع التي تشكل تهديد
للجانب الروسي هذا اذا ما ربطناه كذلك
بالتطور على الوضع الميداني في هذه
المنطقه باتجاه خركيب باتجاه كوبيان
باتجاه هناك محاوله ضغط من جانب الروسي
للضغط على الجانب الاوكراني لعدم احدى
اخراج اي تقدم وكذلك السيطره الميدانيه
بهذا الاتجاه لوضع حد لاي تحرك للقوات
الاوكرانيه باتجاه الجانب الروسي لكن اذا
ما انتقلنا كذلك الى الجانب الجنوبي من
ساحه المواجهه ونتحدث بالضروره عن البحر
الاسود وعن الاستهدافات التي طالت من
اسماعيل وكذلك موانئ في اوديسا هذا يعطي
انطباعا جوهريا لدى الجانب الروسي انه
يستهدف مواقع مهمه هناك معلومات
استخباراتيه يتم الحديث عنها في روسيا على
ان ما يحدث هنا في تلك المناطق وخاصه
هناك محاوله اعاده ترتيب الاوراق الامنيه
والعسكريه من اجل القيام بربما بهجوم قد
يكون شامل او كبير جدا على منطقه شبه
جزيره القرم لذلك الان ربما تتخذ روسيا
المبادره من اجل استهداف هذه المواقع وهذا
ما يبرر للجانب الروسي بحسب تصريحات
المسؤولين الروسيين لاستهداف هذه المواقع
باعتبار انه تشكل تهديدا على مستوى
المسيرات على مستوى التاريخ وعلى مستوى اي
تحرك عن طريق الزوارق المائيه لاستهداف
المقر الروسيه